[Música]
y
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa al espacio de france 24 en el
que les mostramos las noticias más
destacadas a lo largo de la semana
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
a continuación les presento algunos de
los temas que vamos a tratar en el
programa de hoy
hablaremos de la salud mental tras el
regreso a la supuesta normalidad de
nuestras vidas ahora que muchos ya
estamos vacunados y que hemos retomado
la presencialidad de nuestras labores y
también pues que han levantado algunas
de las restricciones en los diferentes
países para muchos no ha sido fácil
regresar a la rutina cómo afrontar
entonces la transición a la recuperación
de nuestras vidas en los modos que las
teníamos antes del confinamiento también
lo vamos a conversar entonces con
nuestro invitado el doctor andrés sergio
rascovsky desde la ciudad de buenos
aires- vamos a hablar del más reciente
anuncio hecho por la opc la organización
panamericana de la salud ya lo hemos
reiterado varias veces en este programa
en programas anteriores los casos de
kobe 19 en nuestro continente van en
aumento y por eso el llamado a los
gobiernos a mantenerse en alerta para
tomar medidas preventivas y no reactivas
veremos cómo está la situación entonces
en nuestro continente y en ese orden de
ideas pues entonces vamos a ver cuáles
son las novedades en países como ecuador
perú y cuba novedades en cuanto a las
restricciones a los planes
y cómo está avanzando la vacunación y el
aumento o la disminución dependiendo del
país de los casos de kobe el 19
comenzamos ya lo decíamos la
organización panamericana de la salud
dio a conocer un aumento del número de
contagios de kobe 19 en el continente
americano este organismo regional alertó
además sobre el aumento de casos
relacionados con otros virus
respiratorios debido a la temporada en
la que estamos por lo menos en
sudamérica en donde está comenzando el
invierno veamos
continúa la alerta por el aumento de
casos de covite en el continente
americano la organización panamericana
de la salud indicó que el incremento
viene de la mano con otros virus
respiratorios los casos de la región han
aumentado durante las últimas seis
semanas ahora a medida que se acerca la
temporada de vacaciones de verano en el
hemisferio norte y empieza la temporada
de invierno en el hemisferio sur tenemos
que seguir atentos y vigilantes
tenemos las herramientas para prevenir
las peores consecuencias de este virus
según el ente de salud regional el
continente reportó 1.087.000 390 nuevos
contagios y al menos cuatro mil ciento
cincuenta y cinco muertes en la semana
comprendida entre el 23 al 30 de mayo un
crecimiento del 10,4 por ciento en el
mismo período de los casos que hicieron
un 43 1 por ciento en américa del sur al
tiempo que el mayor número de muertes se
registró en américa central con un 21 3
% varias naciones como méxico y
colombia- exhiben cifras a tener en
cuenta el primero marcó su tercera
semana consecutiva repunte de casos
registrando un 75 por ciento respecto a
los siete días previos a decirle el
director de emergencias de salud de la
ope s el número de contagios es aún
manejable
es necesario mantener
hemos observado que cuando se relajan
estas medidas
como sólo la villa manuel
en colombia el ministerio de salud
reportó un incremento de las muertes
relacionadas con el coronavirus también
entre el 23 y el 30 de mayo se
reportaron 21 decesos lo demás que la
semana anterior un aumento del 75% la
organización panamericana advirtió
además sobre el aumento de las
incidencias de virus respiratorios de
otro tipo llamado prestar atención a la
hepatitis viral la influenza y la
viruela del mono
a pesar de este incremento en el número
de casos muchos países han regresado a
la aparente normalidad están ya en
marcha algunos planes de apertura muy
avanzados en varios países de nuestro
continente pero que hay de la salud
mental ahora que hemos regresado a esa
aparente normalidad para muchos no ha
sido fácil recuperar sus rutinas vamos a
hablar sobre este tema con el doctor
andrés sergio rascovsky él es médico
psicoanalista ex presidente de la
asociación psicoanalítica argentina
también es miembro de la asociación
psicoanalítica
internacional doctor rascovsky muchas
gracias por acompañarnos en el programa
y la pregunta básica por qué nos cuesta
tanto regresar a la rutina si era lo que
estábamos anhelando durante la época de
los confinamientos y de los cierres de
las ciudades hay personas a los que
mentalmente les está costando mucho
recuperar su vida normal
bueno este es difícil llamar que es la
vida normal porque ha habido muchas
transformaciones tanto económicas como
los lugares de trabajo este trabajo en
las oficinas se ha modificado que el
trabajo virtual se ha incrementado
incluso en la práctica psiquiátrica y
psicoanalítica no son todos los que han
regresado a lo presencial es virtual
muchas veces el trabajo psicoterapéutico
psicoanalítico y esto implica muchas
modificaciones
modificaciones en la práctica de lo que
se llamaba normal que ya no lo es este y
lo presencial se han disfrutado
indudablemente este también hay una
creciente inseguridad en los casos y la
sensación amenazante que incrementa
enormemente la angustia
va va creciendo bueno doctor teniendo
esos factores en cuenta cómo puede hacer
uno para sobrellevar una transición
tranquila de la etapa de los
confinamientos a estos meses que
llevamos de apertura y que muchas
personas apenas están haciendo el salto
del trabajo en casa digamos a recuperar
su trabajo en la presencialidad o sus
actividades académicas cómo sobrellevar
ese ese paso ese regreso a esas vidas
normales como lo dice usted 2
bueno este creo que no tenemos que
confiar los en una falsa seguridad
hay también una sensación de
descreimiento internacional debido a la
pandemia que hemos padecido y las
transformaciones que nos han generado
tenemos que pensar en un futuro este
diferente seguramente en muchas de las
prácticas y en los trabajos y creo que
bueno estoy es es un costo importante en
la adaptación este a las realidades que
todavía no podemos predecir este hay una
hay un descreimiento también en la
conducción en la conducción política y
en la eficacia que ha tenido sirve en
realidad ha tenido mucha eficacia la
medicina preventiva y como ustedes
mismos decía no es ahora la sensación de
la amenaza mortal del cob y es más
limitada la angustia de lo que puede
suceder se confunden con
gripes o
como bits que se disuelven en una semana
o en uno diga yo mismo tengo esta semana
esté gripe y pensé que era kobe me hice
varios tests consulte con algunos hay
colegas de latinoamérica que también
estaban con kobe pero yo no la padecía
en tres días y se olvida su situación
bueno por fortuna doctor rasko es que
eso es una buena noticia usted menciona
la virtualidad definitivamente los
confinamientos nos llevó a descubrir
esta forma de trabajar a distancia de
relacionarnos a distancia y de educarnos
a distancia esto cómo va a repercutir
más adelante tal vez los efectos no se
noten en este momento pero más adelante
cómo va a repercutir en el perfil
psicológico de la humanidad de la
sociedad de las generaciones que nos
tocó afrontar esto a la hora de
relacionarnos a la hora de desempeñarnos
en nuestros trabajos de cara al futuro
yo creo personalmente que va a
repercutir enormemente creo que el
desarrollo tecnológico ha traído enormes
beneficios pero también ha traído la
amenaza de lo virtual y de la
deshumanización la falta de contacto
verdadero es decir cuerpo a cuerpo es
personal los vínculos se van
transformando hay una tendencia en un
aislamiento mucho mayor y éste se ha
planteado incluso la el peligro que
implica para la juventud y para la niñez
este el contacto las horas dedicadas
virtualmente a los juegos electrónicos o
los juegos
con la computadora creo que esto hay que
tenerlo en cuenta en los colegios mismos
es decir es necesario preservar este lo
presencial la capacidad de juego y que
el juego no sea virtual y no los
conducta exclusivamente a la tecnología
creo que es un tema muy significativo y
va atrayendo
transformaciones en la conducta
poblacional en general importante esa
interacción de los menores de edad a la
hora de jugar en los años tempranos de
la infancia del doctor ralph caos que
muchas gracias por estos minutos para
france24 y para kobe 19 la semana en
américa muchas gracias por resolver
estas dudas para nuestra audiencia
muchísimas gracias
vamos a pasar ahora a algunas de las
cifras veamos entonces cómo avanza la
vacunación en diferentes países de
américa latina les voy a presentar
algunas cifras de dosis de refuerzo
inoculación de dosis de refuerzo por
cada 100 habitantes vamos a hablar de
chile en donde han inoculado 110 puntos
53 dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes en argentina las cifras ya
llega a 54 punto 23 dosis por 100
habitantes uruguay 73 puntos 60 paraguay
19.48 es la cifra menor
en el conosur y terminamos en brasil en
donde las cifras de alcanza el 45 punto
0 8 número de dosis de refuerzo por cada
100 habitantes
en cuba esta isla del caribe allí fue
levantada ya la restricción para el uso
del tapabocas ante el alto alto índice
que tienen de vacunación en ese país
también es muy particular el caso de
esta nación porque ha sido el único en
américa latina' que ha desarrollado sus
propias vacunas recordemos que ya han
desarrollado varias de ellas que son
vendidas en diferentes países y vamos a
ver entonces cómo está el perfil de la
pandemia allí en este país para eso nos
acompaña rafael pérez aquí en el estudio
de france 24 la rafael gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en el programa y bueno
comienzo preguntándole entre las
novedades que hay pues ya veíamos lo
mencionaba yo que levantaron el uso
obligatorio del tapabocas allí en este
país caribeño asimismo santiago como
bien decías cuba se sumó la tendencia
mundial de eliminación de la
obligatoriedad del tapabocas el anuncio
fue hecho esta semana por el ministro de
salud pública en la televisión nacional
esta normativa fue acogida con
beneplácito por los cubanos aunque
muchos prefieran salir con su tapabocas
o nasobuco como es conocido allá el
implemento sanitario dejará de
utilizarse en consultas médicas o más
bien tendrá que utilizarse en consultas
médicas que así lo requieran en áreas
donde hay focos de coronavirus y si
usted tiene de síntomas de coronavirus o
síntomas de enfermedades respiratorias
rafael en los casos de contagio van a la
baja allí en la isla lo hemos reportado
aquí en el programa cuál ha sido la
estrategia de las autoridades cubanas
para lograr este éxito por lo menos en
el número de contagios asimismo santiago
el país se encuentra en un momento en el
que reporta unos 39 casos diarios como
promedio según las autoridades
sanitarias
es importante destacar la baja totales
de contagios desde el inicio de este año
fíjate esta cifra a santiago al menos
135 mil
785 casos son los que se registran de
este inicio de este 2022 en un país de
11 millones de personas
la estrategia la estrategia central fue
la vacunación masiva esta se basa en la
atención primaria de salud
bueno y hay que avanzar también que hay
un peso muy importante en cuanto al
confinamiento que
instauraron allí también muchas personas
querían vacunarse había un alto
incentivo para las personas para
vacunarse allí y también la ciudadanía
fue bastante comprometida conexa con esa
medida pasó a preguntarle entonces ahora
por ese nuevo plan de vacunación que han
anunciado las autoridades cubanas en qué
consiste cuál es el porcentaje de
vacunación entonces que tiene esta isla
del caribe y en qué fase se encuentra
también el desarrollo de nuevas vacunas
allí si primero que todo hay que decir
que lamentablemente se reportan desde el
inicio de esta situación pandémica al
menos ocho mil 529 fallecidos en esta
nueva ronda que me conversaba hacer de
vacunación el refuerzo primero se está
haciendo una quinta ronda de vacunación
teniendo en cuenta que son 3 vacunas o
sea la norma normal son tres vacunas
entonces se está haciendo a partir de 12
a 18 años abre el turno también es de
mayores de 50 años digamos qué son dos
grupos
vulnerables por decirlo de alguna manera
en cuba se han administrado unas 37
millones 154 mil escuché bien
750 dosis de las vacunas soberana 2
soberana plus y abdalá hechas por
científicos cubanos más de 9 millones de
personas cuentan con un esquema completo
de inmunización lo que representa a
santiago el 89 por ciento de la
población y ha sido utilizada en otros
países además de cuba aquí te tengo
precisamente el dato las vacunas cubanas
han sido aprobadas de emergencia en
otros países como méjico san vicente y
granadinas siria irán vietnam entre
otros y esto ya significa entonces para
la economía cubana para ese sistema de
salud esto me imagino que genera
ingresos por estas ventas
internacionales de lotes de vacunas
exacto y no sólo por eso santiago
recordemos que el turismo es la
principal entrada de dinero al país
entonces tiene un transfondo importante
para el tema económico el principal el
motor el motor económico del país es
decíamos es el turismo y se dio
gravemente afectado por toda esta
situación
de alguna manera que se vivió en el
mundo entonces lo que conlleva a una
población totalmente inmunizada es
turismo y que suene la caja registradora
como bien se dice en cuba que es el
sector de del turismo que es la chimenea
sin humo pues muchas gracias rafael por
este reporte de la situación en cuba y
ya saben a usar el enlace buscó entonces
también para protegerse como dicen allí
nació buscamos esa gran muchísimas
gracias a ti santiago paso ahora a
contarles entonces cómo va el avance en
cuanto al número de casos y fallecidos
en los últimos 28 días en los países de
centroamérica comenzamos entonces en
guatemala los casos registrados en los
últimos 28 días llegan a los 14 mil 658
los fallecidos allí se cuentan por más
de 520 en el salvador los casos
registrados en los últimos 28 días
llegan a los 660 son un poco más los
fallecidos son cuatro en honduras los
casos superan los 1.400 los fallecidos
son 4 costa rica son más de 47 mil 600
casos reportados en los últimos 28 días
y los fallecidos son 104 en panamá los
casos superan los 83 mil 235 en los
últimos 28 días y 73 personas han
fallecido no hay cifras oficiales de
nicaragua por lo tanto no les damos un
reporte de la situación en ese país
vamos a ver ahora entonces cómo es la
situación en ecuador vamos a conectarnos
con gustavo ortega allí en la ciudad de
quito los primeros reportes gustavo
indican que está cayendo el índice de
aplicación de dosis de refuerzo entre
los ecuatorianos qué es lo que está
pasando allí cuando hay dosis
disponibles para la ciudadanía
hola qué tal santiago es correcto la
aplicación de dosis de refuerzo terceras
o cuartas dosis ha bajado su ritmo en
ecuador según cita en el ministerio de
salud desde la tercera semana de febrero
se aplicaron un poco más de 539 mil
terceras dosis y las aplicaciones que se
dieron mientras que el país andino
atravesaba por un brote de contagios la
caída más importante se inició desde el
mes de abril y la cifra más baja según
datos de la cartera de salud fue de 74
mil 952 primeras dosis de refuerzo la
última semana del mes de mayo fueron
inoculados 78 mil 908 terceras dosis
también es oficial que desde que se
inició la aplicación de las primeras
dosis de refuerzo hasta el 29 de mayo un
poco más de 6 millones de personas
recibieron las terceras dosis de un
total de más de 16 millones de personas
que deben ser vacunadas en este país en
cuanto a los datos referentes a las
cuartas 12 se informó que un poco más de
300.000 personas cuentan con el segundo
refuerzo de igual forma hay un dato que
se registra en el sitio oficial vacuno
metro que todavía existen 1,9 millones
de personas que no cuentan con ninguna
vacuna en ecuador contra la comey 19 de
santiago
gustavo sino comparar las cifras se nota
un incremento de casos de kobe 19 en
ecuador desde que fue eliminada la
obligatoriedad del uso de las
mascarillas que dicen las autoridades al
respecto cuáles son las cifras que están
manejando allí las autoridades
si algunos especialistas consideran que
los incrementos en principio se originan
desde la eliminación de las mascarillas
desde el primero de abril fue levantada
esta medida en ecuador en espacios tanto
abiertos como cerrados y se
incrementaron al cien por ciento de los
aforos en todos los escenarios desde el
primero de mayo se registraron 62 nuevos
contagios en el ecuador mientras que el
17 de mayo pasaron de 211 contagios a un
poco más de 500 casos positivos según
cifras oficiales a pesar que las
autoridades consideran que estos
repuntes todavía son controlables de
igual forma también han dicho que
continuará el aumento de casos a los
niveles esperados correspondientes a la
eliminación de las mascarillas pero
según aseguran no se espera una nueva
oleada de contagios de condiciones en
ecuador en cuanto a la ocupación
hospitalaria se mantiene al 6% y en
cuidados intensivos paso a 36% según
datos del ejecutivo nacional santiago
gustavo hay quienes dicen que parte de
este incremento en el número de casos de
contagio a kobe 19 se debe a unos
errores en cuanto a la comunicación por
parte del gobierno a la hora de anunciar
las medidas o de levantar las medidas y
eso ha llevado a que los ciudadanos se
confundan un poco y algunos se han
relajado pensando que la situación está
volviendo a la normalidad y eso también
debe ser una de las causas para este
incremento de los casos que dicen allí
si algunos especialistas consideran que
mensajes errados emitidos desde el
ejecutivo nacional han relajado
principalmente a los ciudadanos en
principio el titular de salud de cuadro
expreso que la pandemia había terminado
y que el comicio 9 estaba próximo a
convertirse de una pandemia a una
enfermedad endémica en el país el poder
anunció que la vacunación contra la
condición me pasará a formar parte del
esquema regular de vacunación y esto ha
relajado a todos los ecuatorianos otro
factor que destacan algunos
especialistas por el incremento de los
casos es la la eliminación de la
mascarilla de igual forma también
existen cuestionamientos para que el
ejecutivo cree nuevas estrategias para
convencer a los ciudadanos de que se
vayan a vacunar paralelamente en las
últimas semanas se han producido
protestas de médicos de diferentes casas
de salud del país que denuncian que
existen
desabastecimiento de medicamento en los
hospitales del país otro tema que se
mantiene la opinión pública es que según
el plan de gobierno que resaltaban los
últimos días también la estrategia del
ejecutivo es privatizar el sector de la
salud como solución para enfrentar la
actual deficiencia del sistema de salud
de igual forma crear farmacias externas
ante la falta de medicamentos
se hace público las protestas de
pacientes frente a los centros de salud
en espera de medicamentos o de la
pensión pública y de doctores que en
algunos casos han declarado despidos de
los hospitales o de igual forma que no
existen equipos apropiados para
continuar la atención de los distintos
hospitales del país gustavo muchas
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de quito vale la pena la pena añadir que
el presidente lazo también le pido a los
ecuatorianos vacunarse acercarse a los
centros de salud para vacunarse vamos
ahora entonces a perú allí hay nuevas
medidas en torno a la viruela del mono
otra enfermedad a la que le estamos
haciendo también seguimiento en
diferentes países de nuestra región
vamos a conectar en lima con francisco
zacarías para conocer cuál es la
situación allí francisco gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa y bueno
leyendo a algunos de los reportes
oficiales pero reforzó la vigilancia en
los aeropuertos y en los puertos ante la
posible llegada de casos de viruela del
mono
hola santiago debido al aumento de
contagios registrados en la viruela del
mono en diversos países y el elevado
riesgo en la importación de la
enfermedad las autoridades sanitarias se
están reforzando los protocolos de
vigilancia en los aeropuertos puertos y
pasos terrestres del perú césar munayco
director de vigilancia en salud pública
afirmó que es de vital importancia a la
información que vayan a brindar los
pasajeros que proceden de países donde
existen contagios del monkeypox las
acciones se establecen en la detección
de casos sospechosos o probables para su
evaluación y aislamiento así como la
toma de muestras con esta finalidad del
ministerio de salud de este país
coordina con la organización mundial de
la salud la compra de kits serológicos
así como vacunas que la o ms y algunos
laboratorios comienzan a fabricar en
paralelo dentro de los planes de
contingencia se inició la capacitación
de los profesionales de salud de todas
las regiones además se dispuso dos
hospitales con camas aisladas y personal
con trajes de bioseguridad para atender
los eventuales casos de infectados con
la viruela del mono
francisco al igual que en ecuador allí
en perú hay una reducción en cuanto al
número de personas que se están
vacunando incluso hay menos afluencia de
personas en los centros de salud para
vacunarse y por este motivo el
ministerio entonces también redujo su
meta de vacunación para los próximos
meses
en abril el ministerio de salud había
calculado que para junio la tercera
dosis de la vacuna contra el hobbit 19
alcanzaría el 80 por ciento de los
mayores de 12 años pero debido a la baja
afluencia esta meta fue cambiada por las
autoridades y ahora es de 70% maría
martínez jefa de inmunizaciones reveló
que son los jóvenes los que menos
regresan por su tercera dosis las
estadísticas oficiales
reportan que a la fecha la población
vacunada con la tercera dosis bordea el
62% que consiste en más de 17 millones
de personas esto significa que para
alcanzar al 70% faltan vacunar a más de
2.5 millones de ciudadanos algunos
expertos sostienen que muchos peruanos
creen que se encuentran protegidos con
solo dos dosis y dejan de acudir a los
vacunatorios y piensan que la pandemia
se está acabando porque el kobe 19 ya no
es para preocuparse ante este
contratiempo las autoridades trasladan
las vacunas a los centros laborales
instituciones y mercados también
emprenden eventos para concientizar a la
población sobre la importancia de las
vacunas
francisco entonces baja la vacunación y
aumentan los casos esto es directamente
proporcional y por eso entonces hay
alerta epidemiológica en la ciudad de
lima y también en la zona de el callao
que dicen las autoridades ante este
aumento de casos
el ministerio de salud de emitió una
alerta epidemiológica en los
establecimientos de salud del país ante
el incremento de contagios de la
variante omicron del sub linaje ba2
punto 12.1 que se registraron en las
últimas semanas en 10 distritos de lima
las autoridades recomiendan a los
establecimientos de salud a mantener
disponibles camas de hospitalización y
de unidades de cuidados intensivos la
medida procura impulsar una respuesta
inmediata del control de casos mientras
tanto las autoridades han anunciado que
hasta el momento perú ha contabilizado
más de 29 millones de ciudadanos
vacunados con al menos una dosis contra
el coronavirus y la cantidad de
inoculados con dos dosis es de más de 27
millones de personas el país ha
adquirido más de 26 millones de fármacos
de scinopharm más de 46 millones de
facer más de un millón de dosis de
modernas y más de 10 millones de
astrazéneca los ciudadanos disponen de
una plataforma que les ayuda a
identificar los puntos de vacunación y
también pueden acceder a un lugar
cercano donde se encuentran las vacunas
francisco muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de lima entonces
hasta aumento de casos tanto en ecuador
como en perú pero también atentos a las
hospitalizaciones que esto lo que nos va
indicando cómo se va moviendo también el
virus vamos a hablar algunos temas a
nivel internacional vamos a hablar de la
ciudad de shanghai en china que volvió
digamos a la vida después de un duro
confinamiento como parte de esa
estrategia del gobierno de cero cobit y
esto llevó a que cerraran la ciudad y
sus habitantes
estuvieron en una en un confinamiento
estricto para evitar la propagación del
coronavirus en esta ciudad de 26
millones de habitantes pero la alegría
tal parece que no es completa porque
todavía hay algunos sectores que
permanecen en confinamiento veamos
libres tras dos meses de aislamiento
obligatorio
los residentes de shanghai y retornaron
a la vida después de duras políticas de
confinamiento dictadas por el gobierno
chino la alegría era visible entre los
habitantes de la urbe
[Música]
estoy realmente emocionado en este
momento igual que cuando salí a
medianoche estoy tan emocionado que
tengo ganas de saltar al río one y dar
vueltas en el agua estoy demasiado
emocionado sin embargo el júbilo no es
completo los ciudadanos deben hacer
largas filas para realizarse una prueba
pcr o simplemente vacunarse el resultado
negativo o la inmunización es el pase al
transporte o la entrada a un número
determinado de lugares públicos es la
primera vez que me subo al metro desde
el inicio del confinamiento y me siento
bastante bien no está tan lleno ni tan
desierto parece que la gente está
nerviosa me imaginé que nadie lo haría
las autoridades de la provincia han
habilitado unos 15.000 sitios para la
realización de los exámenes el
confinamiento de la ciudad fue resultado
de la política cero kobe de una
estrategia gubernamental conocida por
erradicar los brotes de covite sobre la
base del cumplimiento de un aislamiento
estricto medios de prensa afirman que la
ciudad de 26 millones de habitantes aún
mantiene a unos 2,5 millones de personas
encerradas a pesar del descontento
generado por estas medidas mientras
tanto en la del país beijing se
aliviaron algunas restricciones en
localidades consideradas de bajo riesgo
entre las disposiciones adoptadas el
teletrabajo dejará de ser obligatorio y
el transporte público volverá a la
normalidad gradualmente mientras que las
clases particulares cibercafé bares
entre otras actividades no abrirán sus
puertas todavía
ha llegado el momento para nuestra
habitual consulta con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo y
asesor científico de france 24 a quien
saludamos en esta oportunidad en la
ciudad de cartagena en el caribe
colombiano doctor pérez gracias por
acompañarnos y leyendo varios estudios y
varios análisis a lo largo de esta
semana vimos que hay uno en particular
que trata sobre las causas para que una
buena parte de la población todavía no
se haya infectado de kobe 19 esto puede
ser debido a que la infección ocurrió
antes de que comenzara oficialmente la
pandemia a nivel mundial o que
simplemente pues tienen un sistema
inmunitario muy fuerte que dicen los
estudios doctor
dentro de esa posibilidad de personas
que no sean infectados surgen varias
hipótesis una los coronavirus son virus
que han existido que producen el
resfriado común y estos coronavirus al
producir el resfriado común producen una
inmunidad y esa inmunidad pudo haber
sido que disminuya la probabilidad de
infectarse por los nuevos coronavirus de
otro lado se ha encontrado que algún
grupo de personas especialmente que les
dan severo tienen en la forma severa la
enfermedad tienen unas condiciones
inmunológicas de reducción de
anticuerpos anti interferón que podría
explicar por qué era susceptibilidad y
la no sucedía en otro grupo poblacional
en este momento se está estudiando
porque sería clave para poder generar
estrategias de inmunización en un futuro
doctor ya que usted habla de sistema
inmunitario pasó a preguntarle por
alguno de los efectos del hobbit largo y
algunos casos de kobe largo pueden estar
causados por un sistema inmunitario
anormalmente suprimido esto qué
significa qué características tiene esto
en el organismo de los individuos que lo
padecen
lo que se ha visto como la mayoría de
infecciones y algunas infecta de
espirales es que pueden servir como un
disparador para enfermedades autoinmunes
con el cómic se ha visto un
relacionamiento de algunas personas que
pueden incrementarse el riesgo de
enfermedades inmunológicas o autoinmunes
estas enfermedades son enfermedades que
se han descrito en pacientes que tienen
prolongado y con el gran número de
pacientes que presentaron hoy es muy
probable que esas enfermedades sean más
prevalentes en un futuro hoy hay ya
establecido una relación en algunos
grupos de pacientes de color prolongado
de enfermedades de autoinmunidad
relacionados con el top 19 y eso tendrá
algunas implicaciones y tratamientos que
estamos por ahora en estudios todavía no
tenemos una respuesta para esa patología
doctor hablemos ahora de la vacunación
porque uno de los efectos secundarios
que puede generar la vacuna contra el
kobe 19 es la vejiga hiperactiva en qué
consiste esto y cómo se puede tratar la
vejiga hiperactiva
digamos que tenemos que ser placas
precarios en esa información donde hay
una relación causal ahí puede haber
asociación y eso es lo que se está por
establecer se ha visto en algún grupo de
personas vacunadas pueden haber
fenómenos de una reactividad de la
vejiga quiere decir que se hace mucho
más frecuente la micción urinaria que
puede acompañarse de algunos síntomas
dolorosos al orinar sin embargo está por
establecer si está relacionado con la
vacuna o con la enfermedad o una
condición clínica y lo predisponía y a
raíz de la vacuna o de la enfermedad que
pudo haber generado esta situación hasta
ahora son como muchas de las plazas que
se están estudiando de seguridad de
vacunas después de un año o un año y
medio que estamos vacunando a las
personas y en esta el accidente y
hiperactiva pues está centrado ahoritica
una gran parte del conocimiento a ver si
hay alguna relación o no pero hasta
ahora no hay una relación causal y las
vacunas siguen siendo seguras y hay que
seguirse vacunando cuando retiramos los
refuerzos es claro ese punto doctor pasó
a preguntarle por los sintomáticos o
personas
le pregunto por qué estamos ante un
incremento de causa de casos en
diferentes países de la región y vuelve
entonces el debate de quiénes son los
que infectan más los asintomáticos o las
personas que están presentando síntomas
son los sintomáticos las personas que
tienen más síntomas respiratorios tienen
mayor carga viral y mayor probabilidad
de transmitir la enfermedad lo que
llaman cody distinto otra enfermedad
infecciosas es que las personas
sintomáticas también pueden contagiar
pero en menor proporción son mucho más
los síntomas pues lamentablemente las
vacunas que hay ahora no cortan esa
cadena de transmisión simplemente
digamos evitan la enfermedad grave pero
no cortan la cadena transmisión por eso
independientemente que estamos vacunados
podemos transmitir el virus es muy
importante que si hoy una persona tiene
síntomas respiratorios debe ser
mandatorio el uso de mascarilla y en lo
posible hacer un auto aislamiento es
claro doctor doctor pérez muchas gracias
por esta consulta esta vez desde la
ciudad de cartagena disfrute cartagena
vamos ahora a hablar de brasil porque
las autoridades de este país ya dieron
vía libre al uso de la cuarta dosis de
refuerzo vamos entonces a río de janeiro
en donde ésta valeria saccone para
conocer los detalles valeria gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa ya lo
está mencionando la en la introducción
cuarta dosis de la vacuna para un sector
particular de la población brasileña
cuáles
el ministerio de salud de brasil ha
aprobado esta semana la aplicación de la
cuarta dosis o segunda dosis de refuerzo
en todas las personas mayores de 50 años
ante el repunte de nuevos casos de kobe
que se han duplicado en las últimas dos
semanas hay una media diaria de 31 mil
nuevos contagios todos los días además
en la ciudad de san paolo se está
aplicando la quinta dosis en ancianos y
en inmunodeprimidos recordamos que san
paolo es la ciudad más poblada con 12
millones de personas y también la ciudad
que tiene el récord de decir al cien por
cien de su población totalmente vacunada
en el resto del país es el 77 por ciento
de la población que ha recibido dos
dosis de vacuna
estamos hablando de 166 millones de
personas que se han relajado y han
olvidado casi que aquí hubo más de 666
mil muertos ha habido dos carnavales
este año el último ha sido a finales de
abril y parece que ahora estamos
recogiendo los frutos de esta relajación
y eso también se ve reflejado valeria en
una decisión que están tomando en la
ciudad de sao paulo están estudiando la
posibilidad de volver a usar la
mascarilla de forma obligatoria porque
hay un repunte de casos en esta ciudad
que es la ciudad más poblada de brasil
la más poblada de suramérica
y precisamente la ciudad de san pablo
está estudiando la posibilidad de volver
a obligar a sus 12 millones de
habitantes a usar el tapabocas en
lugares cerrados recordamos que esta
ciudad la mayor de todo brasil había
relajado las condiciones el 17 de marzo
pero ahora ha llegado el invierno
tropical que está empezando en esas
semanas hay olas de frío que bajan las
temperaturas a los 10 grados y hay
muchas más aglomeraciones en lugares
cerrados por eso un comité científico ya
a digamos sugerido el uso de mascarillas
y vamos a ver si los próximos días o
semanas será obligatorio mientras tanto
ya es obligatorio el uso de las
mascarillas en todas las universidades
de río de janeiro y en algunas ciudades
menores de brasil esto nos recuerda que
la pandemia todavía no ha acabado en
brásil
valeria muchas gracias x este reporte
desde la ciudad de río de janeiro vamos
a dar un vistazo entonces a otras
noticias destacadas en redes comenzamos
con este titular cuarta ola de kobe la
argentina reportó 51 mil 778 contagio y
64 muertes la última semana así titula
el diario la nación dos semanas después
de que la ministra de salud de argentina
carla vizzotti confirmó el comienzo de
esa cuarta ola de contagios es evidente
entonces el aumento de casos en la
mayoría de el país principalmente en la
provincia de buenos aires- también en la
ciudad autónoma de buenos aires en las
provincias de chaco córdoba y la pampa
entre otras también destacamos nuestros
colegas de cnn titulan aerolíneas
presionan a la casa blanca para terminar
con las pruebas de kobe 19 previas a los
viajes a eeuu varios funcionarios de la
casa blanca se reunieron con integrantes
del sector de turismo y de viajes y
ejercieron presión sobre el gobierno
para suspender este requisito para los
pasajeros internacionales que ya están
vacunados para que deban someterse a una
prueba de pcr antes de volar a los eeuu
la medida impide la plena recuperación
del sector aéreo y también de la
industria turística de eeuu
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa recuerden la
emergencia persiste la pandemia continúa
sigan cuidando si nosotros nos vemos la
próxima semana hasta entonces
[Música]